we were taught no nutrition and very
minimum lifestyle okay this needs to be
if you're really if you would read a
book this is where you'd get to
highlight marker right and you'd
highlight this this is very important as
they don't learn basics of nutrition I
think in a week he was telling me yes is
he hotter and 10 he got slapped on the
wrist for seeing 108 talked about a
little bit of the benefits now of
Ramadan prophetic this is very healthy
herds of superfood this meal and
hamdulillah assalamualaikum greetings of
peace welcome to the Deen show which is
a way of life we try to put out there
for everyone to see helping you
understand Islam and Muslims now you
heard these words Tibet and hello
Ramadan is coming up and we have a
medical doctor here not just any medical
doctor but we have the author of the
holistic rx dr. Medina a Salam alaikum
how are you Michael arigato so other
than honored to be here thank you thank
you for being with us here tell us a
little about yourself
so I am born raised in Illinois so I had
multiple of the same bad habits that I
love have led most of adults down the
road to chronic illness
I had lupus Hashimoto's severe digestive
complaints
you know acne support dermatitis eczema
allergies and as I was going through my
medical training I graduated residency
from Southland Indiana so I was a new
mom a new wife a new resident all at the
same time and that's when all of my
conditions sort of came to a peak where
I was severely fatigued and I knew I was
just trapped in this body that wasn't
doing what I wanted it to do it's you're
a medical doctor you would think that
okay you're a medical doctor you're at
optimal health yeah but no but what was
so scary is that I was also being thrown
just the medications like oh you have
fatigue no no it's just because you're
you know you your new mom new wife new
resident which could be the case but I
knew that wasn't and I was thinking
tired of just
King steroids and then they wanted to
give me you know other medications and I
didn't feel like nobody was getting to
the underlining root cause of why I was
getting this because every every time I
turned it seemed like I was diagnosed
with something else
and I was getting sicker and sicker
instead of getting healthier and
healthier so I was sick and tired of
being sick and tired so right after
residency I joined this medical practice
where under one roof there was me in
ob/gyn and internist and exercise
physiologist nutritionist counseling
chiropractor massage therapy acupuncture
acupressure homeopathy all brought
together for the complete healing of the
whole person a concept that's really
foreign to us my parents sacrificed
everything for all of us my siblings to
be doctors my brother is an
interventional cardiologist my sister is
a pediatric ICU physician I have cousins
/ sisters and Harvard psychiatry and
psychiatry and Florida and you know
everywhere pediatrics you name and I
have all these specialists but none of
us are have been taught a single class
of nutrition unless I missed it in
maternity no nutrition in medical school
probably just a couple hours in medical
school okay this is what we really apply
in to our patients is in residency so in
residency as a family physician and as
the rest of all my siblings and all the
other colleagues we were taught no
nutrition and very minimum lifestyle
okay this needs to be if you're really
if you would read a book this is where
you'd get to highlight marker right and
you'd highlight this this is very
important that you don't did you know
this Imran that medical doctors they
don't learn basics of nutrition or
nutritionists lifestyles this is the key
to health this is these are the key to
health this was one of those aha moments
when I learned this that was like hold
on you know if you don't learn nutrition
and that's the fuel for good health then
and lifestyle like you said that is
something that is really like you know
profound that you have to know that's
the key to health is nutrition and
doctors know I mean when you go to your
doctor we know that lifestyle is
important but we've never really been
given because because like for example
my husband's
family physician he has to see 28
patient paycheck patients in a day how
many 28 in a day I think in a week he
was telling me he has to see 110 he got
slapped on the wrist for seeing 108 and
so in that many patients in a week in a
40-hour week you are we are we have to
see 15 to 20 minute patients visits
that's it and you're just taught we were
taught in residency that we just ask the
patient to tell us one symptom and one
complaint only and that's all we're
going to address at this time if you
have another complaint come back to me
and another visit but we are not like
that we are not just one complaint we
are not just one organ system we are
mind body soul and it's all integrated
some have some have you actually cut
that down to like 5-10 minutes yeah I
know I mean why is this a moment you
might say well what's the big deal
because you're trying to get a proper
diagnosis you really got to get into the
history you got you know the person but
if you only got 5 10 15 minutes how do
you do that and you can't really really
understand the underlying root cause so
this is where maybe it's good for for a
symptom Commission's it's great okay and
is it true that now I mean medical
doctors in medical school are not taught
how to cure the disease but how does
symptom management that is what's
primarily is that is that true so we are
taught that these conditions do not have
cures
that's another aha moment right there
example that we are going to if you have
high blood pressure you there's no way
you're gonna live the rest of your life
with the high blood pressure
yeah if you are on thyroid medications
they told me when I even as a doctor I
knew and as I was telling everybody else
to when I was in residency until I
really had my aha moment also and with
that when we're on these medications
were on them for life unless your
customer for life I'm a customer for Wow
and this is where my but that goes
against our Deen I mean our D ningxia
tells us a lot about the crater that
happens on earth tells us that look for
every disease he has sent to cure but
they're telling us the opposite now
no cure man you see people don't know
this medication this is really important
for everybody listening so those drugs
aren't actually met they're just symptom
management they're just they're just
like and they all come at a cost so
you're just putting a bandaid on the
check engine what you're doing so I sort
of describe it like a hand or you know
put up my little tree later on but it's
basically all these symptoms are we have
a root underlining cause of inflammation
so if somebody comes in with you know
digestive complaints and SAAM knee and
depression autoimmune conditions like
thyroid problems or even you know any
other cancer all we know that all of
these symptoms can be treated with a
drug we all know the underlining root
causes inflammation this is not new to
us doctors know that if you have
sinusitis
it's called inflammation and the sinuses
we know that if you have arthritis it's
inflammation of the joints which is you
treat with an anti-inflammatory if you
have eczema it's an you give you give
you a steroid we know that there's
inflammation so we know that the
underlining root cause of all of these
chronic conditions is due to
inflammation and so but doctors this is
what explain to the layperson when you
say inflammation yes in a simple term
like how do you explain give us a vivid
some kind of picture and like what does
that mean inflammation inflammation is
what I tell a lame person it's your body
off balance mm-hmm and there is multiple
like there's two different types of
inflammation there's an acute
inflammation and there's chronic
inflammation acute is what we're all
familiar with if you get like that sore
throat or cut if your body a good
inflammation a good inflammation and
then there's the bad inflammation when
your body is constantly being bombarded
with either constant stress or
infections or bad food all these
impurities lead to our body being up in
arms all the time for a short time that
chronic inflammation is okay okay but
over time when your body is constantly
being bombarded and
directions with this toxins and bad food
and stress and all these things it
starts to get confused and when it gets
confused and it starts to create ever
diseases of every stripe is this like a
fire in your butt like a fire these
rages yes inflammation actually means
fire it's a fire within your body yes
it's a fire within our body and so this
is where we again doctors know that
chronic diseases are due to inflammation
that's why we give you
anti-inflammatories yes but the under
but if you still have the water running
you know you can be mopping it up all
you want but if the water is still
running you're still gonna get a flatter
so you're a medical doctor
now you also are dealing with some of
these you mentioned what was it lupus I
had them what yeah you had them yes so
alhamdulillah you were able to get cure
of it and you went against the odds
because now according to conventional
medicine if you have or was it lupus
what else yes support dermatitis acne
eczema allergies severe digestive
complaints all the komono imbalances I I
was miserable yes
as a medical then now as a medical
doctors also they go to another medical
doctor probably for another opinion
so what are they telling you now you're
going to you're who are you going to now
for these conditions so you're going to
a specialist for these people you got a
specialist specialist
even if basically it so here's take
synthroid but I'm like I'm still not
feeling well because I wasn't dealing
with the underlying don't those come
what those come with side effects they
come at a cost and they're not actually
healing you they're just covering up the
symptoms they're band-aiding it it's
kind of like burning is it kind of like
okay putting perfume I'm sorry give this
I just can't our mind like on do do like
you know you're okay you know at the end
that's all you're covering up the smell
but it's still like on cart on the
carpet you know the cat or someone goes
on and you just it's don't bring it up
you're just putting perfume on there and
then some cases this is where I really
want to reiterate to your audience and
everybody listening is that in some
cases you'd need that in order to
control the blaze you need to first put
out the fire okay so you put it out I
put it out but it's that long-term
constant you know when you're not really
addressing the underlying roots
they're getting rid of that do do it
yeah if you're not getting rid of it
then you're not really dealing with the
underlying root causes okay so sometimes
you need it for conditions like - really
because if you have this fire blazing
it's better to you know get in the army
first in an emergency in an emergency
get rid of the fire and then but the
thing is is chronic conditions that over
time we really can if we deal with the
underlying root cause you can then
really even I have had people get off of
olive medication yeah you can kind of
okay firefighters come they put out the
fire and now they keep that water is
good to put out the initial fire man
they'll destroy the whole property they
keep blaze doing it keep flooding the
place now you got now you destroyed
everything inside the house that's
what's happening in the body that's
what's happened that was happening to
you and then at what point did you
decide to go above and beyond and take
control of your health I when I joined
this medical practice I had a I had one
child in residency and me and my husband
were both working 80-hour workweeks
I could your husband is also a medical
doctor he's a medical doctor so he's a
family physician and right after
residency when I was having my I'm like
I can't live like this
I have severely fatigued I can't how am
I gonna take care of my family properly
how am I gonna do proper about that to
Allah where I could barely pray yeah
monitors everything it's affecting
everything everything I just was tired I
was exhausted I was in pain I had joint
pain I was like this is not this is not
for me so I'm gonna take charge of my
life and I started learning from all
these amazing practitioners I started to
apply it in my own patients first before
I even started playing in my own because
my my patients for example my first
patient was a 31 year old with a nine
autoimmune diseases myasthenia gravis
psoriasis like his plan as Sjogren's
Hashimoto's and and she actually was on
the highest dose of Amira and they
wanted to I mean a highest dose of
mestan on they wanted to put her on
Amira and they told her Sawyer's gonna
have to let this live its course it's
like what and this is a disease that can
kill you eventually because it's not
immune disease of the muscles one month
all gone
50% resolution seven months she's now a
scuba diver instructor for I don't man
diseases of the muscles now she's a
scuba diver
detector so when I saw her and then I
started researching this and a lot more
details started applying it to my own
life and therefore when I was able to
heal myself and then since then I've had
a hundred percent success rate and
healing chronic illness with lifestyle
and that to later on I realized that
it's all this Islamic medicine
it's exactly what Allah has told us if
our life still should be is that's all
I'm doing with these patients and now
conventional medicine is really backing
that up that's what it really blew my
mind and I I realized what there was not
a single book out there written for
somebody with multiple chronic
conditions like I was dealing I'm a
family physician so I see adults
children you know everybody everybody in
between and and I want to just give a
pickup the people one source that kind
of covers everything integrative
functional and holistic medicine and one
source for all ages and that's when I
wrote my book the holistic Rx and so and
trying to inspire others that they can
get in charge of their own health just
by getting back to purity now that that
is what we opened up with Talley but
tell you about hello and this is uh how
would you translate that tell you that
because many people they they see the
word but now and it's thrown in there
Allah the creator of heavens learnt is
saying to eat of the TE bat but now what
were you eating before you got the cure
what kind of foods give us an example so
what were you letting into this I was
loading into this you know gift that
Allah has given us I was letting in junk
so we had fake food fake food yeah let
me tell you why
as doctors we were being my husband
Roberto both working 80-hour workweeks
there was free food at our residency
free food
we were not sleeping we're not eating
properly we had free foods we can eat
all the junk that we want and that's
when Oliver when I told you my symptoms
came to a head it's because I was
totally not respecting this body and
with all fake food artificial every
now especially if it's processed you
have to look really careful its parts
fake food artificial food and theab
means pure Pleasant nutritious safe
peaceful something that is good good and
full of more good specifically when
Allah talks about answer Baqarah ayah
number 168 and o mankind either wishes
halal and play up and do not follow
footsteps of Shaitan we I was not doing
that I was eating junk and artificial
foods just like everybody else right now
but when you go to the hospital a place
where you're supposed to get well they
see people are confused because you go
to the hospital and you stay there for a
night a day two weeks and they're
bringing you this type of food because
again doctors are not taught nutrition
so when we aren't taught that and we
don't even we are not even taught or
even told to even look outside the box
of lifestyle how Kyle outlets and
lifestyle can even help we believe that
it can't yes we believe that it that's a
totally different entity and your
diseases a totally different entities
and so this is why trying I'm working
right now I lots of doctors all over the
country and about trying to bring this
into our our conventional medical
practice these are some times and now
this is something we have a display here
this is some while people are looking at
this these are some examples of real
foods we're talking about real food
right people think okay it's something
that's very expensive I can't keep up
with it and there's maybe confused like
okay well I eat this kind of stuff I can
buy this at Walmart you know to me but
what's the difference this is sweet
right but let's give an example what's
the difference between this and a fake
food that looks like this so this what
do you call this these are my I made
them this morning they are my apple
cinnamon muffins apple cinnamon muffins
okay and but there is only four
ingredients in it only four honey
okay honey let's start with that honey
and not now what the honey you use is it
what kind of honey is because there's
like raw unfiltered Anik honey so pure
honey not like they got some honey that
I was watching a documentary it's so
it's a shame it's like they estimate
like 70 percent of the honey that's sent
here some of us from China it's fake
it's they put ingredients that now it
doesn't even qualify as funny
yeah so this is real non damaged raw
honey then you said what else almonds
eggs and when you say eggs is good like
what kind of I have pedantic eggs
organic okay so I'm from healthy
chickens yeah okay and then we have
apples okay all right now compare that
to let's say you go and you look at the
ingredients people are gonna start doing
that and you look into some of these
ingredients you can you can't even
pronounce these ingredients okay and let
me this is why I wanted to really
emphasize that's what we say it's fake
its fake this is real this is real yeah
this is fake
yes and that's the impure foods that
we're gonna be talking about because
these foods that are not viable
so any of these fake foods these
artificial foods that are not playing up
actually affect our body into in so many
different levels so when Allah talks
about food so let's go ahead and talk
about especially with Ramadan coming up
yes
when Allah talks about food he says that
it should be pure quality and small
quantity right and so why your quality
said your quality and less common and
less quantity okay so let's talk about
why those two are important one I want
to emphasize is that the gene aspect
comes into my conversation a lot they're
like oh we have these genes we're gonna
model everybody in my family has
diabetes it's okay I'm gonna get
diabetes so I'm gonna eat what I want
now there's a study called epigenetics
and this epigenetics is telling us that
we can turn our genes on and off just by
our environment and the Quran even tells
us that whatever good happens is from
Allah and whatever bad for happens is
from ourselves and now
that's what exactly what science is
proving is that we can turn our genes on
and off just by our environment and food
is key because especially when it comes
to you know Sarah Burke are a numbers
168 helada and play em so quality is
let's talk about quality the quality of
the food matters because of the fact
that the difference between somebody
with the problem and somebody without a
problem
if we study the same anatomy books and
we if we say the same physiology books
if for all the exact same on the inside
its our environment that makes a
difference and the biggest connection
between our insides and our outsides is
through our mouth I've got but why does
Allah say the worst vessel you can fill
is your stomach why does it like there's
Hadees where if your gut is diseased
your body as disease and if your gut is
healthy your body is healthy and that's
the Prophet SAW so much the worse yeah
the worst vessel you can fill is your
stomach yeah why does Allah say that
there's you think that there are so many
other places because our gut contains a
hundred trillion bacteria that line our
gut lining how many hundred hundred
trillion we're only ten to thirty two
trillion human cells so if you think
about it we are more microbiome and it's
called the bacteria that lives in our
bodies microbiome than we are human
cells then we have 70 to 80 percent of
our immune system lies in the gut immune
system seventy percent in eighty percent
if not more lies in the gut so our
microbiome which is the geese gut
bacteria are responsible for responsible
for digestion metabolism they can turn
our genes on and off epigenetics they
can control that even to the fact that
they can they make 90% of your serotonin
and 50% of your dopamine is made by that
gut bacteria you give an example in your
book genetics the environment being the
gun and yes yeah so this is where if
you're it's like genetics is basically
your if you genetics is the gun but the
environment pulls the trigger that's
what you said in your book yes and so
this is the environment these impure
foods actually go and kill off these
good bad bacteria
when it kills off these bad bacteria
that are doing all these amazing when it
kills off these good bacteria that I'm
doing all these amazing things it gets
replaced by bad bacteria and bad bugs
when that imbalance turns to more bad
bugs to good bugs your 70 to 80% of
immune system is like hey you shouldn't
be here so I go because these bad bugs
are letting things through it should not
be getting there
70 to 80% of immune system is attacking
it leaving immune complexes all over the
body leaving resulting in chronic
disease in every stripe and this is in
in the conventional medical practice you
guys can look it up all the studies are
there and PubMed it's called increased
intestinal permeability and for the
layman it's called leaky gut syndrome
yeah many people are also there's also
another top medical doctor dr. Kelly
Brogan have you heard of here your food
here your mood something like that and
she stopped prescribing the drugs and
many people have she's a psychiatrist or
psychologist psychiatrist the one that
could prescribe drugs and she stopped
that and she talks about depression and
many people haven't also pinpointed this
and they give them the drugs but being
linked to food also absolutely that's a
huge epidemic depression and now
obviously the spiritual component but
some people are spiritual also praying
and everything they're like why am I
depressed they're not connecting it back
to the food and they're going to the
person who's given them more
prescription drugs and that's not
solving the problem and what's really
Subhan o so talk to me about this so
depression can be linked back to food so
subhanAllah subhanAllah subhanAllah
remember we talked about 70 to 80 90
percent of your serotonin is made in the
gut
50% of your dopamine is made of think
got your feel-good hormone yeah and
there's a direct connection between our
gut microbiome and our brain through the
gut through the vagus nerve it's called
the gut brain connection this is what's
so Subhan Allah and this is what science
and now is proving is that why did allah
Glink in surah Baqarah ayah number 168
either wishes Helen and player been do
not follow foot so to Shaitaan because
Allah linked to our gut with our brains
and I decisions and how we feel and how
we in
react with life so yes depression
especially now that it's an it's on a
rise in our margins you know anxiety
suicide rates all of these things are at
epidemic everywhere now yeah it's
affecting even to the eye I mean
yesterday I saw a patient she was 12
years old with severe depression and was
writing to commit suicide what is going
on what are we doing to our children
even not even just this epidemic of
autism is we know that they are
continuing at this current rate if we
continue at the current trajectory one
out of every four children will have
autism by 2033 how many one out of every
four children 25% of our children will
have autism by 2033 that's around the
corner yeah it was one in 10,000 not too
long ago what is it 10 years ago or so
now it's one in every 50 but then they
say one every 50 and then so now it's
just it's just what do you say to me
what do you say to the argument the
counter would be like well we were able
to diagnose it better have you heard
that we are able to yes maybe we are
able to diagnose is better but it's
specifically where I mean like genetics
if you have a genetics problem
yes you would not see that increase you
would see that very stable but because
of the fact that we are fine if we're
diagnosing it better whatever well these
kids are still sick they're still see
they're still sick and it's not genetics
it's our environment that's making it up
yes I'm that also the director of
education for documenting hope and
that's a non-for-profit national
organization dedicated to heal chronic
disease and children yeah and they are
taking 14 children with seven chronic
illnesses and healing them through
lifestyle and fixing their deficiencies
all this pure stuff living purity and
documenting it via media we're putting a
night we're doing an IRB study right now
and and and through media we're gonna
record it and do a video TV show but
what's so cool in the head of the study
is the pediatric neurologist at Harvard
uh-huh and and she even she is she's had
quotes saying that you know she's the
one that's be backing this up the reason
why we're having all these conditions is
because of the fact that our we are
constantly bombarding our bodies with
impurities and every directions there's
toxins in our environment that are on
Erised there's toxins in our gut in our
food that's on our eyes all these
artificial fake environment leading to a
decreased in the gut microbiome leading
to leaky gut increased intestinal
permeability that leads to diseases of
every stripe you can start with like for
example depression anxiety schizophrenia
bipolar autism - digestive complaints -
headaches visual changes thyroid
abnormalities other autoimmune
conditions cancers pain arthritis eczema
you can actually even start to notice
these changes in children very very
young colicky baby ear infections sinus
issues mulch you know yes you can start
seeing these things really young but as
doctors again because we're not noticed
to identify it we just say oh I wanted
to put a tube in the air it's fine but
never really addressing the underlining
food underlying good doctors whose
education to this aspect is limited here
good doctors who hands are tied in most
cases and my uncle he's also a more
holistic minded he was at the Masjid at
MCC and we were talking about how when
you walk out of there because you said
okay what are we doing and when you
start in the moisture and you come out
on a Juma have you ever seen his brother
where you come out and sister I'm
talking to brother asking him and also
to collaborate with this and now they
got the coca-cola which I think just
drinking one of those a day increases
your chances of diabetes by 30% yeah so
you have all of this fake food you come
out to have all the potato chips and the
person says well potato just comes from
potatoes so what's the big deal and all
of the other garbage that's there you
know there's candies and what not to do
given the kids so he goes and he talks
to the Imam and the Imam says my hands
are tied because this is the board and
all that so it goes under the hadith
where the prophet saw some said if you
see an evil you know you change it with
your hands and if you because we think
it's just limited to certain aspect but
this is also something that's is
affecting
our health and kids are dying and this
is one of the greatest blood our
children so if he would have got up the
Imam to educate himself and to also now
speak up and bring the hadith and the
ayahs with your tongue I'll tell you
about but many scholars here are also
limited or they are so busy on other
aspects my law bless them but this is
something that they need to start
getting more educated on even on thigh
Mel Josey one of the great scholars he
wrote a book on this he was someone
ahead of his time was speaks about this
but many of us need to start speaking up
more and replaced those fake foods and
the mustards at least start there and
with real foods those fake foods are the
quality is destroying our gut microbiome
now this is why the were stressful you
could fill your stomach but also the
quantity now that is really scary
because of the fact that it is Allah
puts such a proper moment says I'm sorry
but Heidi Hadees says it believer fills
a stomach with one I mean it fills this
fills one stomach and then a
non-believer like really differentiated
between believer and non-believer fills
a stomach with and what are we doing as
a Muslim Ummah and that's that and this
Asahi boo boo Hadi Hadees is the press
this is how the importance of Allah has
on quality quantity and now science is
proving that when you eat more foods
when you eat fake foods these fake foods
are actually raising our blood sugar
level but raising our blood sugar level
higher than normal than real food does
yes and so this is another epidemic that
our children in 1980 there were zero
cases of diabetes type two in nineteen
i'm een just in 2010 there was sixty
thousand cases of diabetes type two and
now it's even worse diabetes insulin
resistance is such on a rise yes most i
have because i see a lot of kids eight
out of ten kids that I see are
pre-diabetic yeah I've been practicing
medicine for nine years and I'm like
this is I mean out and after residency
but this is crazy because now these
artificial foods are raising our blood
sugar
level that is leasing to pre diabetes
and prediabetes symptom is probably what
we're all walking around with waking
around the midsection fatigue
irritability brain fog acne irregular
periods problems with when you have
sugar crashes carb cravings we think
that our kids are just we're feeding
them junk all these lollipops and all
these things because they oh they love
sugar no it's because they're getting
sick is that their that's why they're
craving love these guys and so and then
it also leads to if you notice when you
go to a restaurant if when you go to a
restaurant
what is the first thing they give you
put the bread on it a bread why would
they give you bread on the table what's
wrong with bread sister dr. MIDI had
many people they say bread is that's a
real food now so alhamdulillah like
there has been no documented anywhere
that the prophet muhammad sallahu wa
sallam had ever eaten eaten wheat hay
barley but he never ate meat yes but our
bread now has been so genetically
modified where it used to be 14
chromosomes and now it's about 44
chromosomes and our body doesn't
recognize it as food but the thing is
it's not just the wheat itself when they
give you this bread at this restaurants
it's fake if you have do they ever look
at the ingredients it's mostly just
completely fake processed refined so
much so that it is destroying our
insides by destroying our insides yeah
it goes actually it inhibits our leptin
and leptin is a hormone for satiation
yes so these fake foods are actually
making us leptin resistance and
inhibiting the leptin which tell us we
don't know when we're 1/3 full yeah you
know yes alhamdulillah Allah Allah
promised awesome says 1/3 eat 1/3 1/3
1/3 but we're eating it we're filling it
with the fake food that is then telling
us by our bodies that we don't know when
we're 1/3 full so then we keep on eating
until we're completely stuffed so this
is not the bread that your
great-great-grandparents is never 100
years ago had that kind of
and this is why there's chronic diseases
such on a rise is because we have been
eating the fake processed red for so
long and if you think about it we have
brown bread breakfast lunch and dinner
there's some sort of grains breath like
a breakfast language and dinner and the
barley that is prophetic now where we
are even reacting to that we're because
of the fact it has various gluten in it
the barley has gluten but the barley
what so subhanAllah about it is it
doesn't raise your blood sugar level but
I when I want to help heal and prevent
chronic illness
I have people stay away from the wheat
as much as possible yes and eat fill
your 1/3 up with the most nutrient-dense
foods that are gonna help heal you heal
your keep your gut bacteria healthy
because that good quality pure quality
good small quantity that is gonna keep
your gut your hormones balanced and your
insulin balanced and your glucose
balanced and then nutrient dense so
whenever even my kids my kids are ten
seven five and two so even when they're
hungry I have them go down the list
uh-huh you know what we want to only
fill the 1/3 up fill it with vegetables
protein and healthy fats all those foods
will satiate you anywhere you're in less
in the kitchen so yay you vegetables
protein healthy fats you spoke on some
statistics what do you think and this
goes back ok so I was mentioning a
hadith where the Prophet SAW sown last a
final messenger sent to mankind problem
Muhammad peace and blessing to be upon
him said if you see an evil to change it
with your hand if you can't then with
your speak out against it and then the
least amount hate in your heart so
people can see okay if someone is giving
my son drugs or about to get hit by a
car you push them out of the way you you
know you stop that evil from coming
these are now when you look at this
something this disaster that's about to
hit a family where tomorrow their kid
can have cancer a disease that can just
destroy their health so of course we're
speaking out against this falls in line
with that now look at this some
statistic what do you think when you
when you hear this you probably you've
heard these a hundred million people in
America today are either pre-diabetic or
have type 2 diabetes that's we
like 325 million I believe in the US so
a hundred million pre-diabetic or have
diabetes 30% of kids have a chronic
disease and you've seen that eight year
old kids with diabetes you have one in
two people have a chronic disease that's
half of America almost one in three have
multiple chronic diseases forty percent
of us here in America are obese thirty
percent are overweight so that's seventy
percent or obese overweight here's a
scarier one in two people men will have
cancer one in three women will have
cancer Wow what's so that's their mind
blowing by hearing this what you just
said it's continuing to rise so that's
the evil the disaster now that we're
going to continue to rise with it or
we're gonna go ahead and make a change
and honor this vehicle of life that I
lost want the law has given us yeah an
awakening needs to happen awakening
needs to happen they need to start in
our Mazdas we as a Muslim Ummah have
Allah we are it we've such a beautiful
religion it's holistic in every aspect
it tells us how to eat live breathe yes
right so but the thing is this is that
one piece of the puzzle that I've
noticed is we are not focusing on in the
Muslim Ummah we getting back to taking
care of this body this vehicle that
Allah has given us by filling it with
you know good pure foods now no
artificial foods that should be just
like we look for gelatin entire body
that's you just we should be looking to
make sure there's no artificial stuff
and then our foods if that's not
playable yes then we have is you want to
make sure that the world around you
you're living in is as clean as possible
these toxins that we put all over our
homes cleaning supplies cleaning
supplies if they kill 99 percent of the
bacteria on the outside what are they
doing with the bacteria on the inside
replacement what can you do okay so
there's natural things you can buy
natural at all these grocery stores you
can even buy natural lemon you can clean
with lemon and what's the other one
vinegar
you can clean with and I do vinegar and
water feels good it's toxic free so
that's another thing so we talked about
food you just mentioned chemicals that
your everyday that you're cleaning with
right our body lotions cosmetics now
that's a whole different Wow do you see
like it's not even just it's it's it's
this pure lifestyle that we really need
to focus on with our environment around
us should be as clean as possible so
you're not gonna be eating it don't put
it on it don't put it in around your
house and that's a good so the
commercial industry is making money
capitalizing and there hasn't been
really many safety regulations and now
we're finding out on the other end you
know the skyrocketing cancers and all
these other things and there's there are
so many hormone disruptors in our houses
just cuz I mean we can't control what's
going on outside yeah but we can at
least control what's going on our homes
yes and it's all about I tell people to
just take one step at a time
soap runs out go buy a new natural soap
detergent where to go buy a natural
detergent yeah because of the fact that
we there's so many hormone disruptors
that are messing up our children and our
biology yes just by being there look at
this one this is just this is
mind-blowing I mean you have you have
this is something people can a lot of
these things they're not complicated
it's really simple to understand it just
taking the time now listening watching
this and then going and doing your
homework and now is a perfect
opportunity because you're detoxing
we'll talk a little bit about the the
blessing of Ramadan and now you're
really you know having this chance
during his bosom blessed month Ramadan
but you know what just came to my mind
we brush our teeth every day hamdulillah
you turn it over and it says you know if
swallow called poison control you know
what I mean the fluoride in the
toothpaste and these two pays with
toxins and just one simple thing can you
imagine that now how many kids are
swallowing you know because we're adults
will spit it out but training a kid to
swallow and it says on the back it says
poison call poison control did you know
about that really
it's that's what we need to just take
one step at a time and get in that right
direction the next piece of the puzzle
that I always work with all of my
patients on and actually start with
start this with my patients is gratitude
the power of spirituality because if we
live a life of frustration they've done
studies where our heart rate variability
goes all over the chest Panama Subhan
Allah and if we are live a life of
appreciation our heart rate variability
is a nice sine wave it's like coherent
now the stress goes the rest goes down
or it lowers our stress levels or lowers
our cortisol levels it just by being
grateful it actually turns genes on and
off and even lowers inflammatory markers
and actually improves heart failure
they've done studies where they've
improves heart failure just being
grateful and it is so Subhan Allah in
surah bakra answer ibrahim ayan number 7
Allah uses a strongest language in the
Quran he says I swear to it I swear - I
swear to it I promise I'm going to
increase you if you are just a little
grateful
just be nice it's just in a letter isn't
specified this is what so subhana lies
Allah doesn't specify who you need to be
grateful for it he doesn't specify what
you need to be grateful for or even if
you need to believe in him or not he
just says be grateful and I promise I'm
going to increase you
that's deep that is so deep and so I
start every one of my patients on
gratitude but now the science is proving
the power of gratitude and we can go
ahead and live our lives we know that we
are we should be a people about hundl in
that we know we should be people we know
you need to be thankful we hear in our
margins on a daily basis we hear it
everywhere we go but the thing is our
environment now we've turned on social
media everybody's lives look perfect
perfect yeah our subconscious governs
about 90% of our thoughts and actions so
if we we and 90% of that subconscious is
like oh my gosh if I didn't have the
best iPhone I should have you know I'm
gonna be depressed if I don't have this
materialistic thing than I should yes
but we constantly immediately look at
the negative not the pocket is in
gratitude is in gratitude so we need to
so I work with my patients and I've been
doing this for the last 30 14 years is
all my patients every single solitary
one patient
immediately when they wake up in the
morning I have them say ten things like
that thankful for and it really makes
such a huge difference and that's not me
doing the healing cuts Allah doing the
healing because he promises it so then I
have them focus on the people around him
toxic friends how many times are the
Prophet Muhammad SAS and I'm saying it
I'm watch your friends make sure you
only hang out with those people that
will lift you up not drag you down now
you're a doctor telling your patients
that this is also something very unique
very rare to find but the Saudis are
there my book I've backed up with five
hundred evidence-based studies in
pep-pep review you can go and use a
science base these are all science-based
they've done studies where just love
heals and they love actually when you
give somebody love and appreciation and
all that stuff they it actually releases
oxytocin and dress reducing hormones
that help you heal from the inside out
and lowers inflammatory markers and
improves your immune system like you
could love really truly does heal and
then we have is so we talked about
spiritual health social health sleep
that's something that again we aren't as
Muslims we are not focusing on we're not
putting an emphasis on that we are sleep
while we sleep we're not using much
energy so it leaves more energy for us
to for our bodies to detox make hormones
to help heal from the inside out and
lower inflammation just by improving
your immunity by just sleeping yes then
we have stress stress leads to 80% of
the complaints that come to primary care
physicians are due to stress and this is
what's so crazy eighty percent of the
complaints that come to primary care
physicians are due to stress we all know
it but who was not taught any stress
management I was not taught anything and
as a new mom a new wife a new resident
me and my husband are both working
80-hour workweeks
not sleeping not eating well I really
wish somebody taught me stress
management during residency I developed
shingles what old what older people
develop
I had developed shingles because my
immune system was so weak and this is
where just by I wish somebody taught us
the power of meditation yoga prayer you
know but we're not taught any of that
because just by incorporating a stress
management technique into your daily
routine you can keep damaging hormones
at bay it's so subhanAllah just by that
in that in and of itself Allah puts a
lot of stress emphasis really there is
one Sunnah that needs to be revived and
it goes back to what you're talking
about
gratitude because usually a person who's
also depressed one of the things is that
they can't see anything good so if we
there's such as shooked where the
Prophet saw some would just fall down
you don't you just fall like some good
news small good news big whatever it is
and you just put prostrate your head to
the ground and you think a lot that's it
so you're being thankful to the small
things small things and then imagine the
great things so you're seeing the
blessings coming so this is also remedy
that such does Shuker you know the the
prostration of gratefulness we have
everything there if we just go back to
the basics of our diamond yeah and treat
this vessel like a gift from Allah and
our children like gift from Allah then
we would not be putting junk in it we
would be taking care of it this is why
Allah says our body has a right over us
we're almost out of time tell us now
before we end we got one of these we got
just the main difference between fake is
that you have artificial ingredients
ingredients in there for a longer
shelf-life is not fresh it's toxic so
here you only had the four ingredients
so it's healthy for you and it's
something now you replace the fake and
it's delicious
and there's no one of the killers
nowadays is the new nicotine is the
white sugar right why brown all the
sugar that now you replaced it with
honey yeah and this is what honey in and
of itself actually do goes in the hold
onto the pesticides in the art of
chemicals in our bodies and flushes it
out super hon Allah Subhan Allah Subhan
Allah and another thing that I did want
to emphasize is when you use pure foods
yes you spend less you spend a little
bit more on food quality but you spend
less on food quantity well when you eat
a lot of fake foods you spend less on
food quality but more on food quantity
and obviously the first one is with the
way that our Deen should and this is
what our normal plate should look like
with I mean you can
this is says whenever I have my own my
patience and my children vegetables
protein healthy fats you have your
delicious vegetables here we okay so
where's the birds okay peppers we have
spinach she talks great antioxidants
really help your body heal from the
inside out then we have is oranges
that's where you'll be for dessert but
specifically we have vegetables protein
you just need a little bit of protein
from how much I'm had a little bit of
protein it's not letting you have to you
know those huge steaks it's just a very
small amount of protein to help see
that's the salmon now salmon okay what's
the difference now wild cut okay
different someone's because there's
salmon out there and so for people okay
they're gonna get the salmon but now
they had the farm raised
why do you want to avoid the farmers
because there's chemicals and artificial
they feed them all that stuff you got
off so this is very very small amount
and then I'll lives like prophetic this
is very healthy
it's a herds of superfood this is
superfood and on top of that it's
healthy fat and this is what will help
satiate you so vegetables protein
healthy fats then we have is if you want
that crunch in that biscuit if we're
there are almond flour crackers out
there these are almond flour crackers
what if someone says okay I just do you
know potato chips comes from the potato
you hear hi you know increases your
leptin resistance it's fake its fake its
fake food yeah you can get stuff if you
really want it I mean in done and
coconut potato chips are fake food
they're also cancer-causing food I've
actually because they try and get in the
artificial oil yeah okay so but they're
here we have is almond flour crackers
you can buy them at wholesalers you can
I am everywhere and a couple are so
satiating that's all you need for that
crunch and then I have all my patients
heal with my so the it's to take out the
bad food to heal you take out the bad
food take out the bad put the good-good
replace with probiotics like sauerkraut
oh I love sorry bro
yes probiotics fermented so fermenting
that's good for the food repairing it
with bone broth Oh bron-bron key
nutrients like vitamin D and fish oil
that we're not getting in our bodies and
then rebalancing with everything that we
just talked about being thankful keeping
the people in and around us happy and
healthy make sure you keep those people
that are lifting you out not dragging
you down sleeping well incorporating a
stress management technique into your
daily routine focusing on vegetables
protein healthy fats eating one-third
one-third one-third intermittent fasting
is all there's science that backs that
up now that it puts our body back into
balance
it helps us detox lowers insulin and
then focus on these healing foods and
then detoxifying our bodies bone broth
easy to make is it so easy so healthy
what do you all we do here is you just
take your gonna buy you know if you're
gonna buy the bones anyway for any meat
that you're gonna cook I just take that
in the slow cooker the bones after
they're done how long do you recommend
like anyway from eight to even 48 hours
depending on how and you got soup so
that's the soup from them from the bones
the new chance from the bone the bone
broth it's so healing it has all your
bioavailable amino acids it has a
glutamine that helps the body heal all
that and then I have people do for detox
purposes I have them do like Epsom salt
baths uh-huh to help really take those
toxins out but specifically really just
got to focus on this so now we have
Ramadan the benefits can we talk a
little bit about before we end now's a
perfect opportunity because now you're
not only spiritually but physically
getting your body and everything in
balance you want to move forward now is
a great time to do that with all the
things we're talking about can we talk
about a little bit of the benefits now
of Ramadan
like
what's going on in the body during the
fast it is amazing subhanAllah
so there is this doctor he's a
neurologist he wrote the book the
obesity code and he talks about he's in
Canada he talks about healing diabetes
healing this chronic diseases and the
way that he does that is by fasting and
he talks about the benefits how it helps
to detox you know when we eat all these
foods especially processed foods it
raises our insulin level to a totally
different baseline yeah so now no matter
what we do we can't bring that baseline
now this is why a lot of people can't
lose weight you hold on to these toxins
but what happens with fasting is now you
take that insulin level baseline and you
bring it down to a totally different
baseline and that baseline now is a
healing baseline you lower your sugar
levels you're able to lose the weight
you're able to lower inflammation
insulin resistance remember we talked
about insulin resistance leads to all of
those diseases yes so if you're able to
then lower the insulin you know lower
the insulin resistance my my
father-in-law he's a doctor himself when
he came to me he was on thirty units of
insulin and he's had diabetes for the
last thirty years he occasionally takes
a metformin now by focusing on this
intermittent fasting by really helping
to detox fasting is amazing has so many
health benefits and now we're in that
we're approaching Ramadan is the perfect
time to get it right many people end up
feasting after the fasting so now you
start off before the break of dawn to
have a nice little meal you can start
off what do you recommend that day to
stay hydrated to get the electrolytes
what do you recommend before as they
start Ramadan and then to break the fast
what are you what are your
recommendations so I have actually I
wrote those recommendations in a 25-page
cookbook yeah that I would love to offer
your give us that code you have some
comment if you text the code 4 4 2 2 2
has type healing eats one word 2 for for
healing
Ewing eats yes Healing eats one where I
texted you text it to four four two two
to text healing eats and I will send you
my recipe book and that will benefit
then for Ramadan but again that's
healing eats text two four four two two
two and it's so subhanAllah so for
example you just go down the list
vegetables protein healthy fats you want
to focus on all of this stuff will keep
you satiated if you're gonna a smoothie
in the morning is especially when
somebody can't get up in the morning a
smoothie is an amazing option you have
your healthy fats you have your
vegetables you have everything in there
like a coke like a I love a chocolate
smoothie in the morning and you know you
put your nut butter you your almond milk
in it a lot of people have issues with
dairy so almond milk in there with ice
cocoa powder which is so many healing
benefits because of chocolate and then
when not unsweetened some dates in there
almond butter I use cocoa powder yeah
and then I just take frozen greens and
can't even tell but um they like that
it's so satiating it you know until
iftar you're actually pretty full yeah
so small goes a long way when you eat
quality foods yeah and then for if Diane
this is what I want to emphasize to all
the mustards out there we need to allude
to be this example of what we need to
open our budgets with we can't open our
fast with artificial foods there's you
know artificial if it's pink it's most
likely a drink is pink it's most likely
artificial you know and things like that
we need to open it with similar foods
yeah okay let's call to action yep a
call to action many people have had
their lip dough sensor like you said
blocked sugar the culprit that is the
new nicotine of our time it's more
addictive than cocaine they've done
Studies on it where the brain is
lighting up just like it does for heroin
or cocaine so it's very addictive and
many people have become addicted to this
now is a time okay that's another
question how do they get off the
addiction how do they break that
addiction how what would you suggest
because it's a dick thing I mean
what do you suggest so I have them all
my patients start off with something
like instead of sugar use honey
okay so replace it you replace it so
it's not like they're taking it we have
what are the replacements I have honey
how about natural stevia yes I love
natural stevia okay organic raw stevia
and stevia honey there's raw maple syrup
out there okay date sugar not that other
stuff what's not the stuff that you put
the pancakes okay
raw organic maple syrup and this a
little bit goes a long way yeah so and
it still just treats but that's how you
really want to look for example if
somebody's stuck with brownies and
cookies and crackers guess what you can
still make what is that you can make
sweet potato brownies there's so many
yeah so you have also that's the code
you put to get those recipes okay I have
25 recipes it's also in my book it's you
can also subscribe
WWE holistic mom MD calm my facebook
page is holistic mom MD holistic my MD
calm and the code is holistic type
holistic eats
I'm sorry healing eats healing eats one
word two four four two two two now quick
call to action so I was saying that okay
now the addiction is there many of the
leaders in our communities that we
talked about the epidemic of chronic
disease cancers you have a
responsibility if you are guiding this
community towards spiritual
enlightenment also this is a thing the
Prophet SAW some said that the greatest
blessing after Iman is health so now the
sheiks the scholars they shouldn't be
obese no they should not be also they
should also be monitored they shouldn't
have like they twin like pregnant and I
don't want to offend anybody but this is
something that we need to shake some
take some people add reality they
shouldn't be obese because they're
certain exactly should be talking about
this because it's gonna be affecting
it's coming the way if it's hit here and
just continue to grow so they should not
allow when they come out of the Juma's
where you have people selling this junk
garbage junk we have a professional here
medical DAR whole list
so we bring you the facts we need to
make those so those are the call to
actions that now replace it with yes we
need to get back to our Deen focus on
whenever focus on halal and Playa but
pier foods whenever we feed it to our
children because our future depends on
it one out of every four children will
have autism by 2033 and that is gonna
continue to rise where does a slum go if
all of our kids are sick they are even
saying sperm count is completely
drastically disappearing where does
where does civilization go that happens
so this is an urgent matter that our
being is so beautiful that it has all of
the tools that we need to make this
happen but we need to put our focus back
on this now I've seen places where
they've they've taken the initiative
they watch some of the programs that
we've done in the past with some of our
nutritionist that come in I'm so
thankful we got you now also a medical
doctor to substantiate these points and
we've seen people eliminate some of the
fake foods they've introduced I was at a
mustard in in Florida I was so happy to
have mangoes bananas the dates I was so
elated when I saw that I said wow you
don't have to film this so it's an easy
fix
substitute it right take the bat out put
the good in Thai Baht and then we have
your book here it's the holistic are
extra guide to healing chronic
inflammation and you can get it on the
libraries I'm the first Muslim woman to
traditionally publish in the medical
field that I know of and I also have
like children's books I have courses I
have I'm trying to make this healthy
lifestyle as easy as possible so I have
all the sources at WWDC um and my
facebook page where I do face book lives
weekly have lots of fun stuff coming up
I have infographics of how to heal but
it all is this so good start there's so
much to you got the material get
educated on this and we talked about
granite so much stuff we covered and if
you implement these things it's only
going to better your life absolutely
yeah what I love it and not to do it in
Ramadan thank you so much for being my
guys my honor thank you thank you so
long the groom to Lanka and thank you
guys for tuning in to the Deen show as I
said the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him after Iman what is
the greatest blessing is your health
take advantage of five the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he said before five and one of those is
take a advantage of your health before
sickness don't let the sickness come and
now you're looking all over for the cure
honor your body this is the vehicle that
gets you through life all the leaders in
the communities they need to get
educated on this it's a simple fix
simple solutions we gave you some of
them here implement it you're going to
be responsible in front of Allah for it
not getting this information out we hope
to see you next time every week kind of
Deen show - and in peace be with you
assalamualaikum